the future of space habitats are one of
intelligent structures maybe not all the
way to hal and the you know 2001 space
odyssey reference that scares people
about the habitat having a mind of its
own but certainly we're building systems
now where the habitat
has sensing technology
that allows it to communicate
its basic functions you know maintaining
life support for the astronauts but
could also communicate in symbiosis
with these swarm robots that would be on
the outside of the spacecraft
whether it's in a microgravity orbiting
environment or on the surface and these
little robots they crawl just a la neil
stephenson and seven eaves they crawl
along the outside of the spacecraft
looking for micrometeorite punctures or
gas leaks or other faults and defects
and right now we're just working on the
diagnosis so can the swarm with its
collective intelligence
act in symbiosis with a spacecraft and
detect things but in the future we'd
also love for these little micro robots
to repair in situ and really be
like ants living in a tree
altogether connected to the spacecraft
do you envision
uh the system to be fully distributed
and just like an ant colony if one of
them
uh is damaged or you know whatever uh
loses control and all those kinds of
things that that that doesn't affect the
performance of the the complete system
or doesn't need to be centralized this
is more like almost like a technical
question do you think it was an
architecture question
right
from the ground up
it's so scary to go fully distributed
yes
but it's also exceptionally powerful
right robust resilient to the harsh
conditions of space what do you
um if you look into the next 10 20 100
years
starting from scratch do you think we
should be doing architecture-wise
distributed systems
for space yes because it gives you this
redundancy and safety profile that's
really critical so whether it's small
swarm robots where it doesn't matter if
you lose a few of them to habitats that
instead of having a
central
monolithic habitat you might actually be
able to have
a decentralized node of a space station
so that you can kind of right out of
star wars you can shut a blast door if
there's a fire or if there's a conflict
in a certain area and you can move the
humans and the crew into another
decentralized node of the spacecraft
there's another idea out of neil
stephenson seven eaves actually were
these arklets uh which were
decentralized spacecraft that could form
and dock
little temporary space stations with
each other and then separate and go off
on their way and and have a
decentralized approach to living in
space
so the self-assembly component of that
too so this is your phd work and beyond
you explored autonomously
self-assembling space architecture for
future space tourists habitats and space
stations in orbit around earth moon and
mars
there's few things i personally find uh
sexier than self-assembling
space autonomously self-assembling space
architecture in general it doesn't even
need to be space the idea of like
self-assembling architectures is really
interesting like building a bridge or
something like that there's
self-assembling materials it feels like
a incredibly efficient way to do it
because optimization is built in so you
can build like the most optimal
structures
given
dynamic uncertain
changing conditions
so uh maybe can you talk about your phd
work about this this work about tesserae
what is it
in general also any any cool stuff
because this is super cool yeah yeah
absolutely
so tessare is my phd research it's this
idea that we could take tiles
that construct a large structure like a
buckyball yeah this is exactly what
we're looking at here which is the tiles
that are packed flat in a rocket they're
released to float in microgravity
magnets pretty powerful electro
permanent magnets on their edges draw
them together for autonomous docking so
there's no human in the loop here and
there's no central agent coordinating
saying tile one go to tile two it's
completely decentralized system they
find each other on their own
what we don't show in this video is what
happens if there's an error right so
what happens if they bond incorrectly
the tiles have sensing so proximity
sensing magnetometer other sensors that
allow them to detect a good bond versus
a bad bond and pulse off and
self-correct which anybody who works in
this you know the field of self-assembly
will tell you that error detection and
correction just like uh error detection
in a dna sequence or protein folding is
really important part of the system for
that robustness and so we've done a lot
of work to engineer that ability for the
tiles to be
self-determining they know whether
they're forming the structure that
they're supposed to form or not they
know if they're in a toxic relationship
and they need to get out
right right if they need if they need to
separate exactly yeah all right this is
like so amazing and for people just
listening to this yeah there's
a lot i mean how large are these tiles
so the size that we use in the lab they
can really be any size because we can
scale them down to do testing and
microgravity so we sent tiles that were
about three inches wide to the
international space station a couple
years ago to test the code test the
state machine test the algorithm of
self-assembly but now we're actually
building our first ever human scale
tiles they're me human size a little you
know a little smaller than maybe your
average human um but they're uh 2.5 feet
on edge length
the larger scale that we would love to
build in the future would actually be
tiles that are big enough to form a
bucky ball big open spherical volume
spherical approximation volume that'd be
about 10 meters in diameter so 30 feet
which is much bigger and grander in
terms of open space than any current
module on the iss and one of the goals
with this project was to say what's the
purpose of next generation space
architecture should it be something that
really inspires and delights people when
you float into that space can you get
goosebumps in the way that you do when
you walk into a really stunning piece of
architecture on earth and so we think
that self-assembly this modular
reconfigurable algorithm for
constructing space structures in orbit
is going to give us this promise of
space architecture that's actually worth
living in
living in oh i thought you also meant
from like outside artistic perspective
when you see the whole thing
it's just with the aesthetics of it
absolutely you know when you like go
like in into vegas
whenever you go into a city
and it like over the hill appears in
front of you and i mean there's
something majestic about
uh
seeing like wow humans created that
it gives you like hope about like if
these a bunch of ants were able to
figure out how to build skyscrapers that
light up and in general the design of
these tiles and the way you envision it
are pretty scalable yes and they're
inspired by exactly what you mentioned a
moment ago which is we have these
patterns of self-assembly on earth and
there's a lot of fantastic mit research
that we're building this concept on so
like daniella roos at sea sale and
pebbles
taking
the power of magnets to create
units that are themselves
interchangeable this notion of
programmable matter
and so we're interested in going really
big with it to build big scale space
structures with programmable tiles but
there's also a really fascinating you
know end of that on the other side of
the spectrum which is how small can you
go with matter that's programmable and
stacks and builds itself and creates a
bridge or something in the future
what do you envision the thing would
look like like when you imagine a thing
far into the future where there's um
so we're not even thinking about like uh
small space wasn't that let's not call
them small but are currently sized space
stations but like something gigantic
what do you envision is this something
with symmetry or is this something we
can't even come up with yet is is it is
there's beautiful structures that you
imagine in your mind i've got three
candidates that i would love to build if
we're talking about monumental space
architecture one is what does a space
cathedral look like it can be a secular
cathedral doesn't necessarily have to be
about religion but that notion of long
sight lines
inspiring stunning architecture when you
go in and you can imagine floating
instead of you know being on the ground
and only looking up in space you could
be in a central node and each direction
you look at all the cardinal directions
are spires going off in a really large
and long way so that's concept number
one
number two would be something more
organic that's not just geometric
so here one of the ideas that we're
working on in mit in my lab is to say
could you
instead of the tesserae model right
which is self-assembling a shell
could you define a module that's a node
a small node that someone can live in
and you self-assemble a lot of those
together they're called uh plesiohedrons
like uh space-filling solids and you
dock a bunch of them together and you
can create a really organic structure
out of that so it's uh the same way that
muscles accrete to appear you can have
these nodes that dock together and one
shape that i would love to form out of
this is something like a nautilus a
seashell that beautiful you know
fibonacci spiral sequence that you get
in that shape which i think would be a
stunning and fabulous
um aggregated space station you said so
many cool words please
plesiohedron yeah so that that's a
space filling
solid the simplest thing to think about
like here okay a cube right so you can
stack cubes together and if you had an
infinite number of cubes you'd fill all
that space there's no gaps in between
the cubes they stack and fill space
uh another plesiohedron is a truncated
octahedron and that's actually one of
the candidate structures that we think
would be great for space stations what's
the truncated part ah so it you cut off
an octahedron actually has like little
pointy areas you truncate certain
sections of it and you get
surfaces that are
on the structure that are cubes and i
think hexagons i'd have to remind myself
exactly what the faces are but overall a
truncated octahedron can be bonded to
other truncated octahedrons and just
like a cube it fills all the gaps as you
build it out so you can imagine
two truncated octahedrons they come
together at an airlock which is what we
space people call doors in space
and you dock them on all sides and
you've basically created this
decentralized
network of space nodes that make a big
space station
and once you have enough of them and
you're growing with enough big units you
can do it in any macro shape you want
that's where the nautilus comes in this
could be design an organically inspired
shape for space station can i just say
how awesome it is to hear you say
we space people i know you meant people
that are doing research on space
exploration space technology but it also
made me think of a future there's earth
people
and there's and there's those space
people and i'd love to unite those too
yeah no no for sure for sure but like
it's like new yorkers and like texans or
something like that
yeah of course you you live for time in
new york and then you go up to boston
and but for tom you're the space people
i know those space people they're
they're kind of wild up there let's see
how that dynamic evolved yeah exactly
there's that culture culture forms and i
would love to see what kind of culture
once you once you have
sort of more and more civilians i mean
there's a human
i mean i love psychology and sociology
and
i'll
maybe ask you about that too which is
like the dynamic between humans you have
to kind of start considering that you
start spending more and more time up in
space and
and start sending civilians start
sending bigger and bigger groups of
people and then of course
the beautiful and the ugly emerges from
the
uh from
the human nature that we haven't been
able to escape up to this point uh but
when you say the plesiohedrons these
kinds of shapes
are they multifunctional like he is the
idea you'd be able to
uh
uh humans cannot occupy them safely and
some of them and some others have some
other purposes exactly one could be
sleeping quarters one could be a
greenhouse or an agricultural unit one
could be a
storage depot
essentially all of the different rooms
or functions that you might need in a
space station could be subdivided into
these nodes and then stacked together
and one of the promises of both tesserae
my original phd research which is these
shells and then this follow-on node
concept
is that
right now we build space stations and
once they're built they're done you
can't really change them profoundly but
the benefit of a modular self-assembling
system is you can disassemble it you can
completely reconfigure it as if your
mission changes or the number of people
in space that you want to host if you
have a space conference happening like
south by southwest i was thinking space
party but space conference is good too
then uh maybe all of a sudden you want
to change out what were window tiles
yesterday cupola tiles and make them
into a birthing port so that you can
welcome five new spaceships to come and
join you in space that's what this
promise of reconfigurable space
architecture might allow us to explore
i've been hanging out with grimes
recently i just feel like she belongs up
in space
this is like designed for for artists
essentially like imagine i mean this is
what south by
keeps introducing me to is there's like
the weird and the beautiful people and
like the artists and
it feels like there's a lot of
opportunities for
art and design
it's like space is a combination of arts
design and great engineering
with a
it's a safety critical with like the
highest of stakes so don't you can't you
can't mess it up and is this is there
first of all you talking about tiling so
neil stevens is obsessed about i don't
know if it's related to any of this but
he seems to be obsessed with like how do
you tell a space that's a commandment
geometric notion like the tessellation
and it's i mean it's a beautiful
idea for architecture that you can
self-assemble these different shapes
and
you can have probably some centralized
guidance of the kind of thing you want
to build
but they also kind of figure stuff out
themselves in terms of the low level
details in terms of the figuring out
when that when if everything fits just
right
for the ocd people like
uh what's that subreddit uh
pleasantly
it's like really fun everything they
have like videos of everything is just
pleasant when everything just fits
perfectly very pleasing all the
tolerances come together
so they figured that out on themselves
and the local robotics problem but by
the way was daniel russ pebbles what's
the pebbles project the pebbles project
are little cubes that have epms in them
electropermanent magnets and they can
self-disassemble so they'll turn off and
so you'll have this little structure
that all of a sudden can
flip the little pebbles over and
essentially just disaggregate they have
to make some pleasing sounds
that's gonna so i'm supposed to talk to
danielle so that i'll probably spend an
hour just discussing the sounds on the
pebbles okay uh
what were we talking about so the
that's because you mentioned two i think
right my third one yeah is there a third
one my third one is the ring world just
because
every science fiction book ever that's
worth anything has a ring world in it
and uh it's just a donut a donut yeah
it's a really big taurus that could
encircle a planet
uh or encircle another celestial body
maybe an asteroid or a small moon
and
the promise here is just the
the beauty of being able to have that
geometry
in orbit and all that surface area for
solar panels and docking and um
essentially just all of what that
enables to have a ring world at that
scale in orbit which by the way for the
viewers we're looking at figure alone
what paper is this from this is a
hexagonal tiling of a torus generated in
mathematica referencing code an approach
from two citations so we're looking at a
tiled doughnut and i'm not hungry so
this is the is this is this from your
thesis or no uh this is probably i mean
this is in my thesis this looks like it
was one of my earlier papers this was
an approach to say great we've come up
with this tessellation approach for a
buckyball and we picked the buckyball
because it is the most efficient surface
area to volume shape and what's
expensive in space the surface area
shipping up all that material so we
wanted something that would maximize the
volume but if we think about ring worlds
and other shapes we wanted to look at
how do you tile a taurus and this is one
example with hexagons
to be able to say could we take this
same tesserae approach of
self-assembling tiles and create other
geometries this is so freaking cool
that's awesome
you